welcome this afternoon everyone this is
the NCBI minute on using idhar X extract
utility to parse blast xml output okay
so what I'm going to do today is to
remind you about direct command line
programs that actually Eric talked about
it's been almost three weeks ago then
I'm going to show you a little bit about
the blast xml output and tell you why
you might want to use that and then i'll
just do a couple of quick examples using
you direct to sort of reformat the xml
output into sort of a human readable
form and to point out you to the xml
might be a good way to save your blast
results for later parsing or whatever
you want to do with them so as i
mentioned previously about three weeks
ago Eric gave a full tutorial on using a
direct redirect is our command line
utility for accessing utilities actually
but it's a way of using the utilities
without having to write a script
yourself this is a set of scripts that
search and retrieve information from
entre what comes with them though is it
is an XML parsing utility called extract
an extract is of the general XML parser
and we're going to show you today that
you can use it the parse another kind of
NCBI XML which is the XML that's
produced by a blast and that's if you
look at the command line there that Eric
had from his talk two weeks ago there's
extract it's piped in to extract at the
end to produce a report from this
particular set of commands they issued
through direct scripts blast and this is
looking at the standalone options
produces a number of different kinds of
structured outputs structured outputs
some of them in particular have more
complete information than any of the
sort of flat file type outputs of PLAs
produces most people are familiar with
the pairwise the pairwise doesn't have
everything in it the other formats here
like asn.1 xml jason and things like
that have more information on the xml
output formats probably the most
convenient ones or parsing in particular
because you can use e direct to do them
and you'll notice here that there are
two different kinds there is a
traditional blast xml and the xml to
which is relatively new
you can also get these from the web
service so what I'm telling you talking
about today is perfectly general in fact
i'm going to show you the example I'm
using is coming from doing a web search
and I'll show you why you might want to
do this from a web search although it
might not be immediately obviously why
you would want to do that so if you
download that if you expand the download
tab on the blast page or download
section on the blast results page notice
you can get lots of different formats
the classic class XML comes down as a
single XML document the XML to actually
comes down as a zip file because what it
has is an individual document for each
of your queries and then there is an X
include document that will let you put
those back together if you need to
sometimes it's convenient to Adam
separate sometimes it's convenient to
have them as one document kinds of what
you're trying to do here is sort of a
view of the XML a little bit the classic
blast XML we've had that around for a
long time as I say you get a single
document for the whole thing and we'll
talk in a minute about when you're
parsing this the thing that contains the
results in this XML is the iteration for
blast XML to as I said you've got a
master document and a document for each
query there's a link here into some more
information about the XML too if you
want to read more about it if you need
to combine them and we will need to do
that today you can use this UNIX utility
called xml l int which will pull them
together for processing the xml too has
a number of advantages one is that it
has full support for taxonomy so you can
get the tax ID to scientific name out of
that it also supports iterative blast
likes I blast them and also sports blast
few sequences which are not supported
properly in the old classic blast XML
and if we're parsing this the container
that has the things in it that we want
is the results as you saw in Eric's talk
if you sire stock but you can go back
and review that if you want when we're
parsing XML using extract essentially
we're doing is is using a set of nested
for loops and we can hierarchy based on
some of the exploration commands that
are part of e direct so we're going to
be using pattern as our highest level
that's the highest level you usually use
then block to indicate a lower level so
we can
the pattern for example in the classic
blast XML will be duration and then we
can look at the individual hits if we're
trying to pull those out as a block
before we go on to the demo i just want
to point out to you that there is a
document this chapter six of a utility's
book that's all about entre directions
so if you have any questions about what
I'm doing today that's the place to look
we don't have time today to go into
great detail about how these particular
command lines that i'm going to show you
or put together but i'll just show you
what they can do and we'll take a look
at what we can produce reports from the
blast xml so i'm going to switch over
i'm going to leave the slideshow i'm
going to pull up some text files that i
have and so this is this text file is
available on the ftp site with all this
information in it basically what i'm
going to do is to show you a blast
result on the web and then we'll show
you how you can download the xml and
then we'll go over to the command line
and just show you how you can produce a
reports from that so let me first get
the plus our ID up this is a saved
search that I made the other day so I'm
just going to copy that URL and paste it
into a web browser okay and so this is a
result that you might see if you did a
web lesser too many people do web less
searches with multiple sequences in this
case I had a bunch of sequences from I
took from the database these are from a
meta-genome from cheap actually from
sheep cut so one of the things that is a
little bit in some cases a problem for
people when they're using web glasses
you've got this multi-part output so to
see the results from each sequence you
need to click on this to get to a new
page and some people don't like that and
they like to have the whole thing so
what you can do is to go up here to the
download tab of the download section
notice that you can download the XML and
the XML too and that's a really handy
thing to be able to do a lot of people
like the archive this stuff you know
I've heard lots of reports of people
trying to save the pairwise output or
even trying to print it out but if you
save something like a structured output
format you can always go back to it and
generate just about anything you want
from that particular kind of report so I
have saved the XML in the XML too and
i'll just show
you that briefly hear it back over on my
text editor here is a classic blast XML
here so you can see what that looks like
and you can see sort of the structure
here see if I can make this go a little
bit bigger so here you can see the
iteration which is the thing that we're
going to cycle over to pull things out
it you can see the hits here that I've
got in each hit is going to have an HSP
which represents an alignment even so I
can even get out of this output if I
want to I can pull out the query
sequence and the hit sequence and the
lad I could basically reconstruct blast
pairwise or any kind of report that
suits my fancy from this output if you
look at the XML to what you'd find is
that you have this XML include document
that basically gives you a way of
organizing this so you could pull this
together to make one document otherwise
what you get is an individual document
for each query sequence here's what one
of those looks like and what's good
about the XML too is I think it's
organized a little bit more rationally
so the set of iteration we have results
we have now reserved iteration for
things like iterative glass and you can
also pull out some interesting things
from this for example you can get the
tax ID that's shown here and the
scientific name which is shown here
these are the kinds of things that you
really might want to get back out of
your blast hopefully now let's just
think a minute and just show you some
simple command lines that you can do
with extract to get things out of here
so these are all coming from a text
document so I've got the webinar notes
in here I've got the traditional blast
XML and then in a subdirectory I've got
those files that come from the XML too
and i'll just show you a couple of
commands here so i'll go back to my
notepad here my webinar notes here and
basically what you do to run one of
these extract scripts as you basically
have to take an input file so what you
can just do is cat the particular file
pipe it into extract and Eric talked
about how these things pipe things
together for example a simple thing to
do is to get the XML structure so if I
go if I take this one
I'll go ahead and pipe that into another
unix command which is more because it's
going to fill the screen that's a very
quick way to see how this thing is
structured and you could pick out that
you might want to go through the
iteration there to get your particular
hits out likewise you can do the same
thing for the XML to hear i've got a
command line that does that now in this
case what i have to do is use that unix
command line XML tool to go ahead and
put those files together before I send
them to extract so I can copy that paste
it in here and again I'll pipe it two
more so I can see the way the last XML
to is structured I can focus in on the
results here to get my particular heads
out if I want to so just show you one
more and that's one where we can take
the XML and basically produce something
that's equivalent to sort of a
tab-delimited output or something like
that so a simple thing to do and I'll
focus here on the XML to when I'm
showing these so one of the simplest
thing to do is to try to get suppose you
wanted to find out what the best hit is
for every query that I used I could use
this command line here this uses this
particular command line argument for
extract called first which gives me the
first of each kind of element and
presents that so i'll copy that one
let's pipe that into more
and unfortunately I've got the font
pumped up so that it's a little bit
awkward to read this but I've are made
it smaller you couldn't see it very well
hope you can see this but here I
basically got it on each line I've got
the query ID the subject ID the title of
the hit sequence and so on and so forth
that's a pretty handy thing to be able
to get out of there a more complete set
of things that I could do if I wanted to
well actually what I have there is
actually a scientific name on the last
one there and then if you go back here
if I go back here the second script here
the second little command line here will
basically present all the hits for each
sequence but i can use another and it
comes out as a long line what i can do
that's a little bit more useful this is
long command line here that takes
advantage of the ability to store an
element as a variable and the arc talked
about this in his talk the other week
basically I can take the query idea
which is a different part of the XML and
then repeat that when i type when i
print out my elements here so that comes
first and then i'll get the ID of the
hit sequence the title a value and the
scientific name of the organism so let's
go ahead and just put that one in there
and i'll go ahead and pipe that two more
now again we have the problem of
wrapping but i think you can see what's
happening here so here's my query
sequence here's my hit one my first hit
sequence and notice that the query
sequence has change as we go down and we
get different ones so i've got each head
I've got the query sequence of subject
sequence the title of the thing I hit
the e value here and then the scientific
name of the organism ok and that's
plenty of things to show you today for
one of these short webinars so I'll stop
talking now and we'll leave the room
open for about five more minutes if
anybody has any questions that you
haven't already asked we can entertain
those now while you're thinking about
those let me just show you a couple of
things here one is that for more
information or
that we have a webinars in courses page
we have a youtube channel this recording
will be up on the YouTube channel you
have a blog in fact there's an article
in the blog about using a direct that's
probably worth your time to look at we
have email list announces and since we
talked about two different things today
we talked about direct how we talk about
blast there's the blast announced and
the utilities announce email aliases it
might be useful for you to subscribe to
those and that link there shows you how
to subscribe as always if you have any
questions in general you can write to us
at info at ncbi nlm nih gov we don't
have any questions okay well i'll go
ahead and wrap up the presentation there
if you think of anything afterwards you
can always write to us at webinars at
ncbi nlm nih govt and we'll do some
other in this series about using direct
with blast and some of the future
webinars will talk about how to take
some of your output and pipe it back in
de direct to get objects down from
entrée for example taxonomy information
or to get the sequences back from andre
and things like that okay well thanks
for attending and i'll go ahead and in
the meeting now
you